hello and welcome to the evan carmichael
show i believe in entrepreneurs
i you know frustrates me when i see
entrepreneurs who have a great vision a
great idea and they're just not making
it and and i know you're trying to do
the best you can and i know you're doing
it for the right reasons you're not just
trying to make a lot of money but you're
trying to to make a positive impact in
the world and if that's you and if you
don't have the people around you who
believe in you and and you're thinking
about you know giving up this show was
for you
now i'm a little bit sick i just got
back from orlando i was doing a shoot
down there and i brought my son with me
i went to disney world
with all those kids there i picked up
something i got sick i'm almost better
but i've got my uh
my honey water with me my lemon water
with me my my producer fernando's
telling me i need to have ginger as well
but i hate ginger so i
i can't do the ginger sorry fernanda
but i'm excited for this show today with
you guys what we're gonna do what we're
talking about how to balance your life
and your work have a why
how to stop being your own worst enemy
and do something every day so
how do you balance your life and your
work
i got a question from one of my youtube
viewers zonata wrote in to say evan i'm
so stressed out i'm doing i'm doing so
much for my business i'm trying to make
it all work
i don't know how to balance my life and
my work and and i'm just constantly
stressed out how do i do it what do you
do give me give me some solutions help
please help
so sonato you know welcome to the club
okay running that business is one of the
most stressful things you're ever going
to do in your life it is for people who
think it's easy
you're in for a world of pain getting
into running the business but there's a
lot of great opportunities and a lot of
great things that can come from having
your own company so here's my advice
okay here's my tips for how you can
overcome
that stress
number one is follow your passion this
is this is the most important rule
in business you have to follow your
passion you have to do something that
you're excited about you have to do
something that when you wake up in the
morning you're excited to go and do and
too many people just try to go and chase
the dollars if that's your only
if that's all you're doing you're not
gonna make it okay you have to follow
your passion and when you're doing
things that you're passionate about
you're not as stressed okay you're still
being stressed
you'll still get stressed out but you
won't be as stressed because you're
doing things that excite you when you're
doing something that you love and that
you're passionate about you're not as
stressed out so that's that's the number
one tip
number two is create a schedule
okay what i want you to do and for those
of you listening who are stressed out
and trying to figure all this out create
a schedule and this applies to both your
business life and your personal life all
of the big things that you need to get
done for the week i want you to put into
a schedule i try to schedule things out
in 90-minute chunks i find that 90
minutes is a good amount of time to get
everything done to stay focused to not
get distracted
and then move on to another chunk and
another chunk so my day is usually
divided into 90 minute chunks with 15
minute breaks in between but creating a
schedule
helps you know that you're going to be
able to get the things done that you
need to get done in your business so for
example you might be stressing out about
this proposal that you have to write
well if you know that on wednesday you
bookmark you know that 90-minute chunk
to work on your proposal it relieves the
stress a little bit it helps you focus
on what you need to focus on today so to
create that schedule and make sure
somewhere in there you're scheduling ceo
time big picture time to focus on your
business
and the last tip is follow your flow
whenever you are in the flow whenever
you are in the zone you've got to stay
there you've got to stay in that flow
because when you are in that flow you're
going to create amazing things so those
are my three tips i want to get to the
calls i have maureen on the line maureen
where are you from and how can i help
hi evan i'm calling from redmond
washington and my question is
i've hired a web contractor i've had him
sign a contract that everything he
creates with a project for my company is
ours am i protected what's your fear are
you afraid he's going to go sell this
thing to somebody else or what's your
fear i'm afraid
that
from my past experience is
is something that he creates he will
take it with him with another company
or
actually use it and sell it to other
people
how did you find this guy
uh
from a friend who i said hey we're
looking for a
web developer and she said let me give
you a couple people who i recommend
and um and then we interviewed this
person and we had him sign this uh
confidentiality contract to protect um
our company
and
he starts next wednesday okay well it's
great that it came from a referral
source and you you've already done a lot
more than most business owners where
you've gotten him to sign that agreement
so
in theory yes you are protected if you
have an agreement that says he cannot
sell this anybody else and the work that
he's creating is for you
the the hard part here is this guy's
going to be a contractor he's going to
leave you know after he's done this site
maybe there's a little bit of ongoing
maintenance but
the hard part is enforcing it
so how do you know that he's not
actually going out and selling this to
somebody else
so you have to trust that he is actually
a man of his word you have the agreement
you can go on and you know your worst
case is going to be you sue him but it's
going to be actually proving that he's
gone out and sold it does that make
sense
yes
so in theory yes you are protected okay
that's the good news
but at the end of the day it's gonna be
is this person
trustworthy and reliable and that even
though you know he signed this is he
actually going to honor his word
did you get that sense when you met with
him
i did and uh and i guess at this point
we just start the project and you're
right if something should happen
we do have that legal document and at
the same time his reputation would be on
the line as well yes i mean at the end
of the day if he was gonna go and sell
it to somebody else then you would have
to sue him right you have to say hey you
can't do this and there are you know
financial penalties for doing that
the challenge a lot of times for
entrepreneurs is
you know you don't have the budget to go
out and afford a legal team to go and
see this person that's the biggest
problem right the same thing happens to
a lot of entrepreneurs who make patents
for their companies and their ideas if
somebody infringes on your patent you
have to go and sue that person and a lot
of times the entrepreneurs just don't
have the strength the dollars the you
know they don't want the negativity of
having to go out and sue somebody so
it's great to have the documentation
there just in case but at the end of the
day it's really going to be
do i trust this person and can i create
a solid long-term relationship with them
okay
so no these are that's a very good
advice i just find sometimes
with web developers uh you're right you
can't really micromanage because you
have no idea what happens after the
relationship is over and you just have
to go
based on trust
yeah
so what i would encourage you to do like
you've done the right thing you've done
everything right so far he came from a
referral source from a trusted friend
you've had you know had him sign an
agreement you've gone through the
interview process everything is perfect
so far
what i would do is in your relationship
with him still try to try to make it a
positive one so when he's there working
with you
don't just treat him as some part-time
contractor who's going to be you know
leaving you after a couple months but
somebody who is
you know think about them as being an
ongoing part of your team so treat them
with respect you know make them like
your company and what he's doing uh i
know he might want to factor in some
kind of monthly or ongoing you know
maintenance with the website you might
need work uh afterwards so let him know
that there's that component to it as
well and hopefully he enjoys you enjoys
what your website is all about lectures
with your business and wants to stay
part of the team and obviously we'll
respect that contract that he signed
thank you so much i appreciate this
advice let me know when you launch and
good luck maureen all right thank you
no problem and for everybody listening
in i know it's stressful hiring people
who you haven't hired before and you're
worried about giving up your baby and
then selling you know all the stuff
you've created to somebody else
do the steps that marine did make sure
you know your contractors come from a
referral source get them to sign an
agreement but then once they're on board
you know treat them with respect make
them feel like they're part of your team
make them feel like they're being
respected and they you know enjoy what
they're working on with you because you
need their ongoing buy-in but they don't
go out and screw you because you don't
want to go and have to sue them right
that just is not worth the time effort
energy money that's going to go into it
okay
hello and welcome back to the evan
carmichael show i believe in
entrepreneurs and i want to see you have
massive success with your company
part of that is going to be having a
strong why
why are you doing this i just came back
from walt disney world and uh
walt disney is the king of orlando
and it was a really interesting story
that i read about him
and he said he was thinking about why he
wanted to start walt disney world and
and saturday was his day with his girls
okay when he was a younger father
saturday was was daddy's day with the
girls and he used to take them to go to
these little parks just regular parks
around his area and he was frustrated
that there wasn't a place that people
could go to to have fun with their kids
so the kids are having fun and the
parents can have fun as well and that's
why he created walt disney world he
wanted a place where people could take
their kids to go have fun themselves and
the kids and it was a personal
importance to him because he wanted to
do this for his daughters it was such an
easy simple
vision easy simple why that anybody can
understand it
and so you want to have the same thing
with your business what's the why why
did you start this thing why is it
important to you when you have an
important why it's easy people to to one
understand it and then two for people to
talk about it right you need to have an
easy message that people can share
it finally also gives people on your
team
a guiding light right so think about how
big disney world is now and how big the
disney company is now if you're looking
at just walt disney world and you're
thinking okay walt disney's already you
know long gone he's passed away
what's the guiding mission
to create new things at walt disney
world because you can't just keep the
same thing ongoing you need new things
all the time it's still having a place
where parents can come with their kids
and all have fun together
that's the guiding mission and it's so
easy for everybody to understand so you
need to have a powerful why for your
business what is your why
i have angela on the line where are you
from and how can i help i'm from uh
dallas texas i own a company called
deliveries on demand it's a delivery
company and uh my question is how do you
find the resources
or investors
for bands or for more
transportation when you have
bad credit like i have the
potential i i have the
uh i have the sources and resources to
make at least
two to three million dollars a year but
i don't have the vehicles
in order to do that how do you find
resources or investors or
or you know people that can help you get
uh you know the
the equipment it's gonna take to make
kind of money
yeah it's frustrating when you see a
huge opportunity and you don't have the
money to make it happen
right and my company i've had the
company for six years and i do make a
lot of money but i could make sure for
way more money than i make if i had the
vehicle
okay hold on you've had this for six
years are you profitable
yes
and have you gone and spoken with the
bank
uh well when i started my company i had
really really bad credit the credit is
coming up and i do have vehicles
actually i have three
and i have uh drivers so i pay a um
i buy all the fuel and i pay payroll and
you know things like that i drive myself
um you know and all the bills are being
paid but the vehicles needed you know
because of the kind of um deliveries i
do i do fast food so i have mcdonald's
taco bueno chick-fil-a i have olive
fried red lobster i have companies that
are not gonna go out of business but to
buy the refrigerated vehicles that is
coming hey those vehicles are
uh sixty to a hundred thousand dollars a
piece
so you know and to keep them running the
maintenance i've already bought two
motors two transmissions we go
everywhere you know because those
restaurants are everywhere so
in order for me to continue or to make
way more i have the potential the
customers would give me way more work
but i don't have the vehicles so i'm
sure if i could find an investor they'd
love to invest in my company but i don't
know where to look
yeah you know what i don't think an
investor is the right way to go because
they're going to take a piece of your
company that you don't need to give up
you just need some financing
you need to get some debt
have you been profitable the past three
years
yes
okay
i honestly think it's time to go back to
the bank and start talking to them again
when you are first starting up a bank
won't look at a business because you
don't have any traction in the history
so they're looking at your personal
credit and if your personal credit
wasn't good they're going to say no you
know banks hate startups
and that's a sad fact but it's a fact
they don't like working with startup
entrepreneurs what they want to see is
that you've been in business that you
have brand name clients and that you're
growing and you're profitable and you
have all of that you've been in business
for six years the last three years plus
have been profitable and you're working
with clients like you said they're not
going to go out of business any time
soon mcdonald's no delay and so on
and so you're also
the things that you need to finance are
things that banks like to finance you
know you're talking about vehicles
things that people you know banks want
to be able to take something away if you
can't make a payment
so you're not talking about financing
you know a staff or r d or things that
you know they can't grab onto they can
they can finance a vehicle they like
that kind of business so i would
honestly go back to your bank and if
they say no start shopping the deal
to other banks because now you're at a
point where it doesn't matter so much
about your personal credit you are an
attractive client for the bank to deal
with all right right well that makes
sense and i maybe i should maybe i just
kind of you know once when i first
started i was turned down so much every
single thing that i have for my business
i've actually paid cash for
so you know i i have i don't have any i
can't i don't have anything to show that
i actually bought my box because i paid
cash for my truck as well as my cars and
my home i'm paying for my home but
because i turned down so much i just
made the money and then went out and
bought everything that i needed for my
business you know and i don't want to
continue to do that i do want to have
the credit i do want to have the credit
to buy at least five six more vehicles
and you've got to get it written down
though you've got to get you know
they're going to want to see financial
statements
right so they need to see that you have
been profitable i mean you're telling me
i trust you but the bank's not going to
say hey i trust you yes i have the proof
of the profits because the companies
that i deal with are so big so they
should check so i have six steps i have
i have everything i need you know as far
as proving the profits but you know it's
just i was afraid of the credit i think
yeah well i mean the worst cases are
going to say no but now you're honestly
in a position where it makes the most
sense this is the business that they
want to finance and i don't think you
should go to an investor because they're
going to take you know 25 percent of
your company where you don't need to
give that up you just need some
financing
right all right
yes i appreciate that advice no problem
no problem good luck thank you
no problem if everybody listening banks
do not like the startup entrepreneurs
they don't like you know they will look
at your personal credit but once your
past a couple years they want to see you
know three years of growth that is a
great opportunity to get in and get
financing especially when you're
financing something that the banks can
take away
like equipment like like vehicles then
it's a great time to get in and get the
financial go talk to the bank the worst
thing to do is say no i recently got a
question from one of my readers anna who
wrote in to say how can i stop being my
own worst enemy and she's constantly
afraid she's constantly self-sabotaging
and she's wondering what do i do how do
i break out of this fear zone
so first of all anybody who's going
through this this is totally normal okay
you're not alone
people don't wake up with their
businesses entrepreneurs don't wake up
every day always super excited okay
that's that's
one of the big lies of entrepreneurship
okay entrepreneurs are constantly afraid
and constantly doubting themselves and
wondering is this the right thing to do
or not okay
it's great to have something that you
believe in that you get excited by but
you're not always super excited and
you're always you are gonna be afraid so
it's okay
here's how to overcome it okay i have a
shirt that i really like to wear uh that
that shows where the magic happens okay
there's a little circle that says where
the magic happens and then there's
another circle that says your comfort
zone okay you have to understand that
for you to do great things you have to
step outside your comfort zone that's
where the magic happens outside your
comfort zone so to do the things that
you want to do that big vision that you
have
you're gonna have to be
a better person you're going to have to
stretch yourself you're going to have to
learn new things and so when you're
trying those scary things you can tell
yourself well this this is what i need
to do to get to where i want to go
number two is remember why you're doing
this
if you're afraid of something remember
why you're doing this and again
hopefully it's not just to make money
you're doing this for a reason right
like walt disney made disney world
to have a place he could go celebrate
with his daughters that's why he was
doing it you should have a powerful why
as well and when you're afraid of
something you can think back to that
powerful why
and that can give you strength you think
of your daughters you think of your kids
you think of whatever that reason is
that gives you extra strength to keep
going
and the last one is practice okay when
you're doing something for the first
time it's scary
because it's the first time you're gonna
be scared it's okay
and as you do it more and more and more
you get better at it and it becomes less
scary
i remember the first time i went to go
do a a keynote presentation
one of my first ones that was flown out
to brunei in asia and i thought it was
going to be a small presentation ended
up being in front of this huge room a
thousand plus people it was being
broadcasted on their national tv like oh
my god i'm not ready for this this is
this isn't what i thought it was gonna
be and i was i was afraid you know my
heart's pounding i kind of secretly hope
they would they would say okay you know
whatever that's off don't worry about it
we don't have to do it today you ever
get that feeling
you're excited but afraid of something
and you hope they're gonna cancel on you
i don't know why we do this
but i got up there
and it was great and it was it was
awesome and people were inspired that
day and i left
getting stronger as well right i left
having felt stronger for having overcome
that fear and now i can go do it again i
get up on a stage and i'm not nervous
anymore i'm not i'm not stressing out
over it as much anymore because i did it
and so you have to practice even on a
small scale practice practice practice
and as you do it over and over and over
again you get better at it i think about
even these radio shows
the first show that i did you know i've
been a guest on radio shows i hadn't had
my own radio show before
i went to uh to new york and i was doing
it from a new york studio and i was
nervous and i had my agent there and you
know putting a lot of pressure on me to
have a great show and giving me all
these last minute tips and remember this
remember this remember this like ah just
let me do my thing
and i was nervous for that first show
but then i did it and then the next show
became easier and the next show making
easier every show actually became easier
and
you don't want the fear to hold you back
from doing something great so it's okay
to be afraid but don't let it hold you
back from doing something amazing with
your business i want to get to the call
i have alan on the line alan where are
you from and how can i help
well i'm in uh southern california how
are you doing today
i'm good we're in southern california
um i'm in long beach
oh nice nice the beautiful day out here
wind blowing through the palm trees it's
awesome
what can i help you with
well i have a wedding business i have a
wedding officiant business
and in my wedding efficient business i
uh i want to expand nationwide
i want to take my concept and bring it
across the u.s
um i have a unique and
amazing concept
and i've become the number one guy in
southern california i have the largest
company in southern california doing
this
and i think this would make a great
national business and i don't know
whether to to try to go the licensing
route or the
you know
which way to do it
okay
what prevents somebody from doing it
themselves what's so unique about this
and why is it unique to you i think what
makes it you know pretty much anybody
could do it themselves yeah anybody can
get license to perform a wedding
ceremony but what makes this unique and
what makes it special is the way we go
about it and the marketing approach that
we take i've been able to
pretty much take the entire market in
southern california or become the most
famous because i know how to market
and so we would take these marketing
tools and plug them into each different
area and show people how they can make
their group of people you know form a
coalition of the the best people in the
industry and dominate the industry and
dominate the market in their area
that's something that doesn't come easy
how much can i make
in this business and how long would it
take to get in there
well that depends on your uh
your abilities
i mean
i've taken 10 years to get to where i am
now
but in that 10 years i've learned what
works and what doesn't work
so i can use my strategies to pretty
much instantly
get in and show people how to dominate
their markets
i mean so if you're if you're gonna you
know if you're gonna pitch this you're
gonna make it this is a potentially
franchisable concept okay yes but
you have to
give somebody a model where you can give
those numbers with certainty now i know
you're just getting started figuring
that out yet but
if i'm standing up with you you got to
be able to tell me you're going to make
approximately this much
in this amount of time if you follow xyz
okay
right so all right
maybe you don't know that yet but you
kind of have to figure that out and it
could be depending on the model
depending on the you know size of the
market they're going into
but you know you want me to pay you a
fee right typically with franchises is a
upfront fee so i'm going to pay you x
000 for this
for your coaching and training and then
i'm going to pay you an ongoing fee
which is
huge percentage of the revenues
uh usage percentage yeah right so
potential revenues you get either
monthly quarterly annual whatever it is
you agree on
but you have to understand your role now
is going to change
where
it's going to be harder and harder for
you to run your business in california
you're going to be your business is
going to be supporting these people
around the nation
because they're going to need your help
right and that i don't have a problem
with you know i i guess hiring
people to assist me is where
the best part of that's going to come in
you know if i did it myself i'd go
absolutely insane to run the entire
company so that's where i would have to
delegate
and bring other people in to do that i
assume correct
yeah yeah
this the a lot of people you talk to any
entrepreneur who's gone in franchise you
you lose
the focus off of your current business
and end up focusing on just supporting
franchisees
and so you have to be prepared for that
growth what i would probably do for you
to start is just find one person
so find somebody who
who maybe you've spoken with who who's
in a different uh who's maybe close to
you or maybe in a different state or
whatever it is one person who you can
work with
and show that listen it took me 10 years
and i got to this side but i took this
person and in six months they're already
making you know x thousand dollars a
month and are growing
then that's a repeatable model to expand
with
okay
is there one person in mind that you can
work with
um not off the top of my head but i'm
working on it i tried opening up a new
york division but the guy i uh
i brought in was a
a doink
that's going to be your hardest part
alan the hardest part is finding good
people
that that i have found out
yeah
that i found out in in any in any case
in any part of a business finding good
people to work for you work with you is
the hardest thing now now let me throw
this into the caveat um i'm working on
several fronts of getting a reality show
on the air
once that hits i assume my
opportunities will be
substantially larger and
be more accepted where people would want
to buy
into this once they would see something
on tv that could give you a lot more
attention i would say though be careful
and just focus on one thing at a time
okay
one thing at a time if you're gonna do
your reality show do that first make it
amazing and then focus on expanding
through franchises because if you go the
franchising route you're gonna have to
be that's gonna be your full-time gig
okay okay
i've gotta wrap up i know i i'm excited
for your business i know there's a lot
of areas of opportunity and and it's
great to see that with a growing
business but focus on one thing at a
time like your reality show and some of
you listening you have lots of
opportunities in front of you do one
thing make the reality show great make
that your full-time thing make it great
make it amazing the best show ever then
move on to the next thing because we
like to start fires as entrepreneurs but
the key is to make one huge fire and let
it go from there
welcome back to the evan carmichael show
i believe in entrepreneurs i want to see
you have massive success with your
company and part of that comes from
doing something every day you need to do
something every day for your business if
you're doing your business part-time
full-time doesn't matter every day you
got to do something to grow it i just
came back from florida and when i was in
orlando i was so sick you think i'm sick
now i was so super sick i was popping
apples every four hours
and on wednesdays i usually do videos
and i do 14 videos every week and i
thought oh man i'm so sick i don't want
to do these videos but i had to do it i
had to do something every day for my
business too and you could go watch the
videos they're on my youtube channel
right now you can you can hear like the
massive frog in my throat but i'm still
answering people's questions and i
didn't put in a full day but i had to
get something done and you need to take
the same approach with your counseling
there's always reasons why you can't do
something okay i'm still feeling sick i
could have called in to my producers
today lauren and fernando said hey guys
you know what i'm sick i can't do this
show
but i got into the show the show must go
on i need to do this for my business and
also for you guys because i like talking
to you and helping you with your company
so stockholm with excuses every single
day you have to do something even it's a
small thing but every single day helping
to grow your business i want to get to
one last call i have sharon on the line
sharon where are you from and how can i
help
hi evan i'm from toledo ohio
welcome to the program what's going on
well
i have a business and
i really love what i do i'm it's like
the passion of my life i've been doing
it
like naturally it just comes to me and i
do it
and um when i'm
in the thrust of doing it i
don't think so much about the money
because it just comes so natural but i
do want to make money from it so
what do i do i mean
what changes
what are you doing
um i have a business is called diva lab
and within this
diva lab i teach sacred
sexuality
so
i
i talk to people about um how to have
uh celebrate their
awareness of their energy and who they
are
and um
just to awaken to the energy within them
so they're not dismissive themselves
and um as they embrace themselves then
they can invite other people into their
space
okay so
um when i talk about this to people then
of course it generates a conversation
and then i find myself then going into
really sharing techniques and different
things just on a
you know conversational basis
and this these are things that i would
like to generate people back maybe to
my
workshops or
to engage in a one-on-one maybe
consultation
or something like that and so then i
find myself not making money
so what's the problem are you not making
money with this business yet
i'm sorry say that again
are you not making money with your
business yet
i make some money yes
but i'd like to make more
and so the challenge is what people
you're talking to people they're excited
by it but they're not signing up for
your workshops or your training
right yes
why do you think that is
well i
think maybe i give too much information
i go into too much details
when they ask the question
i don't think so i don't think you can
solve their problem right away on the
spot you know with
with two minutes of talking to them they
should be wanting more why aren't they
wanting more from you
um
let me see
um
well if i think that to yesterday i
had a conversation with someone and they
were
open and wanted more it has to be me
somewhere
then i have i'm stopping
and not
pursuing continuing to pursue
do you let them know about your business
do you let them know you have workshops
and you have training and coaching
yes i do tell them that yes okay and are
you are you proud of this business and
what you're doing
i am i enjoy what i'm doing i do find
myself sometimes hesitant about giving
uh
the details
um
because of the content of some of the
things that i do
i noticed that like it took you a while
to get into what your business was
actually all about when you called in
you spoke for a minute about how much
you love it but like what is your
business
right right
this i mean there's no reason to be
embarrassed by it it's it's a
important topic you can help a lot of
people like millions of people this is a
huge potential opportunity for you
and i think maybe going in with that
belief
will help like if you are proud of what
you're doing and you have the confidence
that you can help people
that'll inspire confidence to want to
say hey i want to i want to work with
this person
right like you need to be the expert i
believe that you know what you're
talking about but there's you have a
you have a
gap in your confidence somewhere
that is
putting off his vibe that you know
you don't you're not as much of an
expert as you actually are like i think
you have the skills but you don't have
the confidence to
to push it forward and make people
believe in you right and yes what i was
thinking before talking to somebody
think about all the people who you have
helped like really help right you you
have made major life changes for some
people is that right
that's right yes so like think about
that like think i know i can help people
with this problem that they're facing
and
you think about it like most people are
going to be afraid to talk about their
sexuality especially the complete
stranger right
this is a sensitive topic so you have to
make it okay for people to talk about
that
where if you're not okay talking about
it then it's hard for other people to be
okay talking about it right yes
yes there should be i talked about
sacred sexuality and why this is
important for people to awaken the
energy within them
you need to make that
zone of comfort open for me to feel like
i can come in and share with you
oh okay okay
okay
i like what you said about think about
the people that really have i've felt
that have come back and said wow
you know
that's a good place for me to
to jump off from that is your starting
point okay
all right good luck sharon
thank you so much
no problem no problem everybody listen
in you have to have confidence in your
idea i know it's hard when you're
starting but do that think about the
people you've helped i know that you can
really help people
we've got another show fully wrapped up
it's crazy how fast the hour goes i want
to thank lauren and fernanda my
producers thank you guys so much for
bearing with me when i'm sick i'm on
again in two weeks i look forward to
hearing from you good luck growing your
businesses and continue to believe